[Music]
hi I'm Stacey Greenbaum and I'm the
costume designer of broad city Stacy has
been with us from the beginning she was
sort of like that immediate friend whoa
I love that outfit you Kalyn Stacy has
such a great balance between looking
good looking fine looking bad but like
I'm not gonna fully hate myself while
I'm editing for me it's been like well
how would the character dress how am i
differentiating myself from this
character Abbi typically does a lot of
physical comedy so whether or not it
caters to that is usually kind of an
important factor we play with color and
pattern imprint and I'd say that this
season we've kind of been able to go the
distance on that you know what I think
you need to change on something a little
more casual like resort wear this is
where Alana who's sort of an occasional
dresser she likes to be like outlandish
and a little wacky but we kind of go
from like zero to 60 on her can you
remind me again why you asked me to meet
you at what turned out to be a sex store
because I need a second opinion on a new
leotard omana wanna process with Abbi
and Ilana has been extremely
collaborative sometimes we're leading
and then sometimes Stacy leading we just
want it to feel real when I'm looking
for new inspiration I'm also looking to
sort of what is the arc of their life
because that actually influences a lot
of the choices that we make this is a
season where Abbi and Ilana are both
kind of starting fresh everyone is gonna
see how freakin hot you are today
including you
one of my very favorite pieces from this
season this jean jacket was kind of a
reference to a Don King jean jacket also
again a great collaboration where we
sort of picked Alana's brain like who
are the women that are important to a
lot of Wechsler and then we kind of went
from there it gets really fantastic and
says a lot about Alana it looked
beautiful on you tonight so may one of
the things that's really fun this season
is that we do a flashback episode thanks
again for swag from the end oh you're
welcome ma'am well she did a lot of
research on 2011 we had to imagine Abby
and Alana individually without the
influence of one another one of the
trends that we wanted to bring back for
Abby was sort of this whole peasant Free
People moment and belting things that
truly needed no belting I was always
like belting stuff flying and your your
flats were horrible hey Florida was a
big Stacey episode so cute we are family
now this is an outfit that Abby where's
the condo board meeting when it's sort
of this big deciding moment funny thing
about the Florida outfits we're like we
kind of looked cute they're not just
ridiculous there are seven changes for
each of them so we really do a whole run
around
thanks for the full new wardrobe if
fashion is art that you're wearing we
are wearing subtle nuanced comedy the
fitting process is so fun and sort of
the way the girls right really lend
itself to these really amazing costume
moments this dress on dusit mia broad
city is such a dream to work on it's
something that I relate to it's
something my friends relate to and I
think this season especially with
everything that's going on it just feels
really good to be a part of a show that
encourages women and really everyone to
just like be better to do better and to
like support each other and that's kind
of what the shows about
[Applause]
[Music]